that someone is poisoning dogs in an
area of town and neighbors want to be
alert and let other people know about it
yeah so this has been going on for years
in just one particular part of the
valley the eight news now i-team's david
charns talking with the man whose dog
died and now taking matters into his own
hands this is scary as dog owners you
know we don't want this to happen and
whoever is doing this
is rolling up poisonous seeds into
meatballs and then throwing them into
people's yards killing these dogs at
least four dogs have died over the last
several years more than a dozen getting
sick and now this community wants all
this to finally end
every day i used to let them out they
had free roam of the yard now we only
let them out when we're out here with
them sean cornwall won't let his dogs
out without him fearing they could eat
poisonous balls of meat someone is
throwing into yards here in the lakes i
think they're looking for dogs keeping
track of where where they're at making a
mental note going back and then throwing
throwing stuff over the wall the last
known dog poisoning happened in november
i think for sure that this guy still is
active maybe not on my
on my street right now because of
everybody's looking out for it
cornwall's network of cameras plus four
roving security guards may be deterring
this serial dog slayer whose actions
killed cornwall's two-year-old dog
several years ago now he's hoping to
raise money to expand this network
pushing the homeowner's association and
the city to trim trees and put in better
street lights it's very hard to catch
this perpetrator because it seems that
he comes and he goes councilwoman
victoria seaman says metro police are
working the case but it's a neighbor who
may see something out of place that
could lead to this case getting closed
we need your eyes and your ears if you
see someone in any area throwing food or
something over a fence
please contact law enforcement cornwall
fears this person may have moved on
moving to another part of town or worse
i seriously think this person is a
psychopath this is where they start
birds cats dogs and they work their way
up through the progression to humans
now there is a ten thousand dollar
reward to find this person who is doing
this and in addition cornwall hopes to
raise money on a gofundme page they want
to hire a private investigator and put
in more of those cameras there we have a
link to that fundraiser on
eightnewsnow.com so david you showed
video a couple times of that of that
meal you said there were seeds or
something in it yeah so what it is is uh
it's actually a rodent killer that's a
that's a pesticide
people use it to kill like gophers and
stuff
but sadly it can cause a dog to have a
really painful death because they end up
bleeding internally they have seizures
people find their dogs having these
incidents and they bring them right to
the emergency vet but you have to be
quick otherwise um you know we've seen
four of these dogs die and this has gone
on for quite some eight years crazy so
now they hope this is the end okay
thanks for the update david